مونيا الاقتصاد العالمي خلال العام الماضي
باسوا معدل نمو اقتصادي منذ حوالي 21 عاما
وذلك جراء التداعيات الاقتصاديه غير
المسبوقه لحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا هذه
التداعيات تشمل تفاقم معدلات التضخم
العالمي والقفزات القياسيه في اسعار
الطاقه وقيم البنوك المركزيه الكبرى برفع
اسعار الفائده مرات عده مما تسبب في تهاوي
قيمه العديد من العملات الرئيسيه امام
الدولار الامريكي بشكل لم يسبق له مثيل
منذ عقدين فقد اعلن الصندوق النقد الدولي
ان معدل نمو الاقتصادي العالمي هوى الى
ثلاثه واربعه اعشار في المئه خلال العام
الماضي كما توقع الصندوق ان يتراجع هذا
النمو خلال العام الجاري الى 92
وان يبلغ هذا النمو ثلاثه وعشرا في المئه
خلال العام المقبل
كما كشف الصندوق ان معدل التضخم العالمي
قفز الى 88 اعشار في المئه خلال العام
الماضي ياتي ذلك وسط تفاقم اسعار السلع
والمواد الغذائيه العالميه لاعلى مستوى
لها على الاطلاق خلال العام الماضي
وتحديدا خلال شهر مارس اذار المنصرم فقد
قفز مؤشر منظمه الامم المتحده للاغذيه
والزراعه الفوري اسعار الغذاء الى 159
نقطه وثلاثه اعشار في شهر مارس اذار وهو
اعلى مستوى له على الاطلاق
وفي منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
قفزت اسعار المواد الغذائيه لاعلى
مستوياتها منذ عشر سنوات فالدول العربيه
اجمالا تستحوذ بشكل عام على ربع صادرات
القمح العالميه وكانت تستورد 60% من
اجماليه احتياجاتها من روسيا واوكرانيا
اكثر من ذلك حذر صندوق النقد الدولي من
تفاقم فقاعه الديون العالميه اذ قفزت قيمه
هذه الديون العالميه الى اكثر من 300
تريليون دولار في منتصف العام الماضي
لتصبح قيمه هذه الديون تعادل 350 في المئه
من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي العالمي وحتى
الدول العربيه قفزت قيمه ديونها الى
تريليون ونصف التريليون دولار لتصبح هذه
الديون تعادل 94% من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي العربي اما في سوق الاسهم فقد
اكدت وكاله بلومبرج ان الاسهم العالميه
خسرت نحو ثلاثه عشرات تريليون من قيمتها
السوقيه خلال الاشهر السته الاولى من
العام الماضي ياتي ذلك بينما اعلنت الامم
المتحده ان عدد الاشخاص الذين يعانون من
الجوع في العالم قد ارتفع الى حوالي
828 مليون شخص اي بزياده قدرها نحو 46
مليونا باختصار لم يشهد العالم منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه تداعيات واسعه النطاق
كما في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا التي طالت
شظاياها قطاعات اقتصاديه واسواقا حيويه
كثيره في العالم شرقا وغربا